my name is tyree robinson hi guys i am a
senior musical theatre major and
polyester you spoke a little bit about
transmedia brands and i'm wondering if
there is any room right now for young
artists to come in and create both
artistic and profitable new brands and
where those ideas might lie things that
can be mess kind of I hope so we need
new brands please do I really I just how
many Barbie Barbies the movie can we see
I'm being facetious but really of course
there's new worlds open in that and
please there is time for new brands now
it's a little difficult to create a new
brand because it's so expensive to
market movies but please do start with
the theater the areas where things kind
of emanate from our and I ran into to
Carnegie Mellon graduates who were
writing graphic novels and they set
chopped up at comic-con you all know
about comic-con and they were writing
graphic novels I don't know what program
they are in but I know our
discriminability went to Carnegie Mellon
and so you have other areas while you
were you know looking to write the great
screenplay or the great play or all the
various things the video game business
is exploding right now in many ways and
you there they're always need writers
animated features need writers directors
actor voices I guess but all these
worlds you have you have publishing you
have there could be webisodes I don't
know how you do webisodes and monetize
them I'm Stephen could speak to that
even better than I I don't know how you
do it but somebody
somebody should discover it a couple if
you want to come out of school and do
things and be a little lofty for a
moment and not talk about the pragmatics
of it just so you know PS my first job
out of Carnegie Mellon when I needed to
make a little bit of money was going to
work at john robert powers for five
bucks an hour while i was going on
acting auditions and I was able to pay I
told them I was 24 I was actually 21
because you had to be older and they
assigned me to teach a class called bras
and girdles that was my first job I had
that job for a couple of weeks but write
a screenplay you all have ideas go write
screenplays right place create a video
game tell us how to solve the problem of
piracy you create if you can create a
system that can stop piracy on being
half a say she's here you will have
buildings named after you on this campus
or any canvas I mean you know specific
to you sir as a musician you know I
think I think music is artistic heroin
it's it's the fastest most direct way
into the bloodstream of culture in the
world that we live in and you're a
musician figure that out how to use
music to create some kind of a brand
because music is such a young person's
world and you're you're a young person
so go work with that you know it's just
the fact that your training is musical
theatre doesn't mean that you can't kind
of do one or the other at any given time
so yes
there was yes yes go get it Hunter hi
I'm hunter seagroves i'm a senior acting
student and my question is somewhat
multi-layered and I'd like to ask it on
behalf of the rest of my classmates in
the third year grad students all of us
who were about to break into this
industry and i was wondering because
obviously we're the only the only ones
we can be immediately responsible for
all the times ourselves being prepared
and staying tenacious but i was
wondering a lot of the senior actors
will be looking for representation at
the end of the year and if we're
fortunate enough to get managers and
agents and stuff like that and i know
that there Hollywood is populated by a
lot of different types of people and I
wondered if you could speak to maybe
give us some advice of developing a
savvy for judging people's character and
also the types of agents and agencies
that you two like to work with
professionally so we like no you know I
obviously there are wonderful little
boutique agencies and what are the
benefits working with that or like you
know some of the larger more corporate
agencies and just talk a little bit
about your experiences with that and
what we can look for in order to
surround ourselves with the right types
of people are going to be one quick
answer and I won't speak on Paul's
behalf but but I'll extend this to all
of you if you get out there and you have
any question about somebody who wants to
represent you call me and if and if I
can't give you some you know informed
input about that I'll get you to
somebody who can you'll call me I'll
call I'll call juni you know Lauer
Johnson and I'll say you know hunter
called me and you know some guy by name
is Sam suppository wants to represent
him you know who is that guy and is he
legit so call me it opens up a very good
question very good topic though on the
role of the alumni and the strength of
the alumni and would you like to just
comment on that a bit border well I
think the networking and I there I
believe there is one but it's something
that you all should look into to even
strengthen there are two create almost
an alumni Bureau where you where you
come out so you go out to LA and there
you I got your suitcase and you stand
there and did anybody see Rock of Ages
on Broadway you know the girl that comes
from Kansas and chief rives on Sunset
Boulevard puts her suitcase down and you
know ends up going to all the wrong
places and all the wrong people that
kind of classic there should be and I
think there is an alumni association
where you can call up and ask any of
those questions you have access to
screen actors guild a proper reputable
agent will be franchised through the
guild so you just call the guild and go
is Sam your but they're the you're
talking about is he register and they go
no we don't have a Sam whatever that's
that I know
um and and the man you know I think
agents it's pretty easy to check them
out managers is a little and there are a
lot of really good managers and managers
has become more of a necessary evil how
do you get the validity because managers
can charge you anything agents can
charge you only ten percent and you only
pay an agent when they get you a job and
if they never get you a job you never
pay them managers same thing I wouldn't
pay any manager more than ten percent
just FYI negotiate everything is
negotiable so use your negotiables your
goshi ating skills and check it out go
online and check you know there are
there's a lot of online sites that will
lead you to managers agents there are
sites where you can register his actors
but and and that are legitimate you
that's what the learning process is
because it's constantly changing someone
who was a shyster in my day my you know
might not even be in the business now
and so a new shysters turn up every day
so you just want to you just want to be
very careful and you're smart you have
good instincts about people you are
trained actors so you can look in
people's eyes and you can see are they
honest are they telling the truth they
looking down to the floor I had a
production manager in Prague on a movie
who would not look me in the eye as he
was telling me how much money it was
going to cost and you know suddenly he
couldn't speak English as well and he
would not look me in the eye and I said
to my line producer I there was
something about this gentleman he would
not look me in the eye we discovered he
was cooking the books so you know there
are there are those little signs and
things and for young ladies also be be
aware be skeptical and be aware
no foreign young gentlemen all of you be
aware of what people ask of you you
don't need that job so badly that you'll
do anything to get the job do not ever
be desperate particularly with your
background there is a place for each and
every one of you I'm about to burst into
song now there's no business that's
great advice that's great advice knee
all right hi my name is Nick ducati i'm
a senior actor here and over the last
few days we've heard and we've talked
about and read about all of your wild
successes and and that's what we're you
know in the world's can remember you by
and i was wondering you know we as young
actors we're about to graduate and go
out there and we and they always take
the road to success is paved with
slip-ups and times that you fall down
and you have to pick yourself up dust
yourself off and and go at it again and
i was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about how you personally have
have you know kind of encountered those
slip-ups and then as producers and
writers have gone about you know getting
people to then buy into your you know
your idea and your and your passion
again after that and just a little bit
about what what it is to you know is it
is it just putting all of yourself and
all of your passion behind something or
is it what you know that's my question
well first of all kudos to you for
figuring out the mic problem so you
already have a little bit of initiative
there you know for me at my end you know
looking at you through my end of the
telescope you at you have before you
earn that
success you have to earn credibility you
know credibility is an incremental
process that earns you the trust of
people like Paul Wagner or Steven Bochco
or john wells or or Peter or anybody you
know and it usually requires you to be
doing things that you may think you're
better than you know but if you do them
that way you won't get the credibility
to do the next thing you know that
what's that hoary old cliche door there
there are no small parts there are only
small actors you know you do that small
part with as much commitment as you
would do the bigger part you thought you
should have had and that gets noticed
and then you know you say okay that
that's a professional person and you
earn that credibility and over time a
lot of it also is beyond your control
you how old you sir you you can't get it
from 21 to 30 without passing through
two three four five six seven eight nine
you just can't and and part of the
reality that young artists face is a
perceived lack of maturity it's a little
easier for actors because you can go
read for the role of a 21 year old it's
it's it's a little more problematic for
writers directors designers producers
because we're all looking for execution
you know we're all interested in talent
but in fact when you're spending a
hundred million dollars on a movie what
you're really looking for is execution
you want somebody that you can rely on
to do that job so that you don't have to
constantly look over that person's
shoulder and that comes with some time
and some experience and you know those
are the slips and stumbles along a way
that that inform you know your your your
career and and and give you the maturity
level so that at a certain point I'll
say you know what I can trust this
person to do this job you've earned it
so it's a journey pull you know there
are times when there's a learning curve
and there are times when there is no
margin for error and that is something
that you learn and there are certain
things you learned from pure experience
and allow yourself if you to be a
learning person I am learning I'm
learning from the few days I've been
here I feel that I'm a more
knowledgeable wiser person from having
been here with sharing time with you you
thought I was giving I was getting
something that so everything is a
learning experience but you do need to
have I say the movie business is a
business of rhythms your you have your
musical people you hear the rhythm of
something there's a language that's
spoken so speak the language it has a
lilt it has a movement it has dynamics
know when to push know when to pull know
when to step forward no one to move back
a lot of this it's like getting in the
ring and kind of knowing where your
opponent is and
move it sports analogies I use sports
analogies all the time in business and I
don't even know sports that will and I
use and talk about that homerun it was a
home run you know he got up to bat
that's right as though you know that's a
kind of guy talk and kind of as a woman
once in a while you got to have a little
bit of guy talk in there you know I got
past the 50-yard line but it sounds good
it sounds like I really know what I'm
talking about but its rhythm so there
are times when you're making a movie say
there is no margin for error none and if
you if you don't go to home base you
don't get there you're out so and then
there are times there's a little
learning curve I supported a client who
was a direct a film director I was an
agent at the time but really
passionately helped him put this film
together I thought it was just
interesting and it was taking all kinds
of chances it was really the wrong time
format financial world to be trying
something it was called out Arizona
dreaming so the cast was like this crazy
cast Jerry Lewis Johnny Depp Faye
Dunaway were the three leads now for
starters there's something very
incongruous about that now it might work
but it was pretty crazy the film was
never in an English even though it was
all shot in America it was in s it was
in Alaska in an igloo where they spoke
Eskimo language and then it was at a
border town in Arizona Arizona dreamin
where they only they start speaking
Spanish actually I think there was a
little bit of and it was a used there
was a little bit of English
and after that was a used car salesman
who's trying to travel across country
and the director was a Hyuga slob then
you be sloppy and director who didn't
speak English so nobody on the crew
spoke anybody else's language because it
was produced by a french producer who
also didn't speak English well need i
say it was a recipe for disaster uh I
should have known better um it was a
mistake I'm sorry I me but I learned I
learned from that so yes it is paved
their gold is on that pavement but
underneath those gold things there's a
few few pieces of gravel lurking there
and you just learn as an actor I can
remember auditions that I walked in and
literally stood there going I am
completely done I am doing a horrible
job here I have blown it completely
they're looking at me like this is not a
good sign when your audition thank you
Thanks yeah next next that's not a good
sign I had I had those experiences too
and I would go what happened why did
that happen and I would always always
take your missteps or the wrong choices
you make look at them analyze them and
then don't do them again I have a rule
of three in my office when people work
with me the first mistake you can make
it because you're learning so let's sit
and analyze why did you make the mistake
was of communication was it was it you
didn't hear me you didn't know what we
were talking about was it ignorance what
was it let's fix it okay so that's the
first time if
make the same mistake a second time then
you have to say wait a second am I not
paying attention to my self to the
others to situate let's really get down
fix this so it never happens again and
if you make the mistake the third time
the same exact one you're out so the key
is you're going to make mistakes just
don't repeat them Frank hi I'm a frank
Capello i'm a senior acting major ever
since my freshman year i've noticed a
kind of trend with the actors that have
graduated from the program versus the
split to new york and LA and a lot of
the actors who have initially Gondo LA
have within 8 to 12 months decided to
switch and move back to New York I'm now
speaking with some alumni I've been
hearing things along the lines of if
you're going to go to LA really give it
at least two to three years before
you've decided to can it so I was
wondering if either of you could speak
to the the pace of each city how they
differ what to expect and you know how
we should be tackling our lives in our
careers in different ways and you know
what what kind of variables they're
going to be that will affect us in each
city we actually talked about this an
hour ago in our last session both Los
Angeles and New York have thriving film
and television communities New York's is
a little smaller but it's it's active
and and it's doable in the age of the
Internet it's very easy to be in New
York and be seen in LA we put people on
tape all the time you know and then we
down load that stuff to Casting sites
and you know and if we love somebody in
New York and we want to meet them
hop on an airplane and we bring them out
so I think those initial choices aren't
either or you know each each coast has
its own advantages and drawbacks and a
lot of it has to do with personal
choices personal needs maybe you have a
relationship in New York that you want
to maintain you know so that will
influence your decision maybe the
economics of New York work better for
you versus the economics in LA where you
have to have a car and you know those
are all practical life choices but I
don't think you can make a wrong choice
probably the only mistake in any of it
is to leave either place that quickly
because then you know then actually it
feels to me as if you've wasted eight
months because I don't think that's long
enough to really you know sink your
roots a little bit and and and get it
develop relationships get your network
going but there's a there's a lot of
back and forth so I don't think you make
a mistake going your place Stephen can I
ask you when all the schools of people
are graduating do you get word amongst
the sort of agency community saying oh
there's a really top person who's just
coming out of NYU or there's a top
person or a great singer dancer coming
out of Carnegie Mellon do you hear that
sort of chatter generally not unless
it's in this in the content context of a
specific project we're doing yeah but I
don't as a matter of course get those
annual phone calls about all you've got
to meet this person or meet that person
or somebody really specialists coming
out the volume of traffic coming out of
schools of is so huge that it that it's
hard to
whatever you gonna um no I don't really
because that a casting director might
hear that it it's I'll give you a couple
of my thoughts there may be a little
more off the beaten track than you might
hear from kind of straight down the
middle reasoning and logic but I think I
think there is no I think you're going
you young talent or going out into a
more interesting world but a more
difficult world in the sense that people
are looking for what's new and fresh and
hot and young and let's make it happen
and let's go there quick quick fix quick
quick quick quick let's make a lot of
money and get in get out and I don't
think there's a concentration of when I
was an agent on building talent and
building careers so that's your
responsibility you really have to learn
how to be your own agent and how I
became such a good agent for myself that
I think a game but you really do in a
way because nobody else is going to care
about you as much as you would like it's
why when I became an agent I became the
agent I always wanted as an actor
because you have to care the most about
yourself and take care of yourself go
where you are the most comfortable if
that's regional theater nothing wrong
with that play a few leads get some get
some confidence unless you think you are
going to go to Hollywood and get the
leads in movies or series is going to be
built around you're going to have the
media is going to be right then and
there I would really develop your own
instrument in your craft further your
talents your experience your life and
unless I have a theory about LA and I've
lived there now most of my life but I
did go to New York and I did a quick fix
stint in LA and I too was one of the
people that left
because it was a little overwhelming
it's all spread out and there's no sense
of community and unless you really know
la you know how to get around you've got
a car you got a place you got it down
and you know where all the studios and
where everything is and you you've got a
network of friends and you can go right
into a theater group and and work
there's a lot of theater groups in LA
now by the way a lot of people going out
there unless you really got it down have
an agent have a manager I didn't go out
to LA cold i went out and immediately
got an agent first day was there i got
an agent I didn't get much else after
that but I had certainly not an agent I
so I did a bunch of television I played
a a rebel space cadet was really one of
my more glorious if you are comfortable
on the stage and you have an incredible
musical theater training I think there's
a lot of action in New York and you feel
comfortable in your go there first
because as Stephen said you're going to
look in New York movies go to New York
to cast there's a lot of movies getting
cast there ironically it's a bunch of
movies here in Pittsburgh that are
casting there's more movies being made
in Pittsburgh right now than in
Hollywood so you have the luxury to go
anyplace go to Chicago there's some
great theater coming out of Chicago be
very pragmatic you don't have to it's a
myth to think that you're going to run
to Hollywood and be a star in that you
have to be there be brought there with a
purpose don't just go hang and figure
you'll figure it out I know a lot of
people parking cars waiting tables
bartending you know who are actors in
Hollywood there are a lot of other jobs
that people are doing there while
they're looking for that track so if
you're an actor go where you can act act
act act act act put a theater group
together make a play together do
readings together my company my Carnegie
Mellon graduates we have readings of
screenplays every couple of weeks and I
bring Carnegie people in and we read and
we talked through material and we
analyze it and you know do make your
life your business life as creative as
it can in terms of furthering what your
own goals are right is that Molly ice
who's next day i am gul pradhan i'm a
director in my last year and and as a
director I find that a lot of the
discussion having to do with what the
procedure is when you get to to LA has
to do with presenting a product whether
it be yourself as an actor and your
audition or as a writer your ideas and
your script is the director I'm finding
myself a little bit loss as to what how
I can how I can introduce myself to that
world not just as someone who deserves a
job but also someone that has something
to say as an artist so if you have any
advice for directors trying to break in
well to two things I mean somehow find a
way to make a film you know if I'm
looking for a new writer I want to read
stuff that that writers written you're a
director you got to make film we don't
do it that often but we have hired
people to direct off of a little
independently made film 12 minutes long
15 minutes long you need to have that
calling card in the alternative you find
entry-level jobs in production so that
you can you know advance your education
in ways that that endear you to
to the community that you're working in
so that at some point people say well
it's her turn and you get that break
because you've been in the environment
doing other things and and in the best
sense ingratiating yourself to to the
people who hire because they you know
David and spa who's became a very very
successful feature film yeah started out
for us on Hill Street Blues as our
location manager and two years later we
gave him an opportunity to direct he was
wonderful you know on his career took
off from there he made an investment of
two years of getting in the environment
doing something else so that he could be
worked it from the inside so I think
those by the way those those are also
not mutually exclusive tracks make a
film ended that Molly hi Oh Molly
mccurdy i'm a senior drum turk which is
a new program here at Carnegie Mellon
and I think we've been toyed it as
chameleons and I just much know as a
researcher and someone who's there to
strengthen not only my own ideas but but
in a collaborative spirit the ideas of
others and make sure that we all
function as an autonomous group where do
you see the role of drama Turks in in
your fields and and what kind of roles
could we play because it hasn't really
been laid out for us it's like you could
do anything but anything is anything so
I don't know why tell me a little bit
more about what this course of study is
dramaturgy for me I guess as dogwood
says main dramaturgical question is why
this play now you work with the
directors and the designers and the
actress and make sure that everyone's on
the same conceptual page making sure
that if you're doing a new adaptation
why is this relevant to today's audience
and how can we really communicate the
ideas within this text in the most
succinct and interesting way so it's a
lot of a lot of research based and
making sure that everyone's using the
same language and that language is being
articulated in a dramatic way so we we
have one of our graduates right now out
in Hollywood she has the blog Hollywood
dramaturg and she talks about strip
script doctoring or avenues like that
doing kind of research-based worse I
think you can do anything I I think that
you serve a very valuable purpose and
there's a lot of things you can do
actually you're very good position
research every movie that's made needs
research i have extensive research done
on every project i do so research story
editors readers analyzers working
assisting directors producers becoming a
producer and frankly even though you may
not have majored in writing producing or
directing any of those related fields
because particularly now more so than
ever when you are rien when Hollywood
seems to be reinventing the
tried-and-true reinvigorating the brand
if you're going to do that and broadway
is doing it too if you're going to do
that you
need to know what how it relates to the
zeitgeist of the times here of the
moment how it becomes culturally
significant why you choose to remake a
movie or a play or and so working with
small production companies working with
studios going into the creative
executive tract going up all the way to
to heading up development of the studio
hey sherry lansing started in your
position more or less running
development and ended up being the first
woman to run a studio so you have it
you're you you have a a gateway to many
different things it's true it's just
you're starting with the the written
word and the story and the thing the
core of what the narrative if you will
and an analytical a narrative analyzer
and use the internet that's a very good
idea blogging having a Hollywood blog
there bloggers you know people pay
attention to certain bloggers so there's
all kinds of what about producers even
going to consulting firms to get some
direction or ideas about what might be
popular what are the trends is that yeah
the producers think about definitely
definitely producers are always looking
for ideas yeah you know Brian Grazer
who's a pal of ours it was a very
successful movie producer he has a
person who works for him who is his
conduit to the world it's kind of what
you're talking about brian is this this
endlessly curious fellow me he always
wants to meet and talk to an interesting
person about something he doesn't know
anything about and he's always been that
way he's been he's very tenacious about
it and so given his world
with all the sort of tentacles he's got
out there he he he would be very
interested in talking somebody like you
you know because he does that if I were
in the movie business I would be very
interested less so on television I'm not
sure why I say that except that my own
sense is that I do most of that for
myself you know when I will if I get an
idea that I'm enamored of as I start to
do my own homework I guess because
ultimately I'm responsible for writing
it causing it to be written I want to be
that person who digs in and does all
that stuff myself and gathers that
expertise around me but if I were more
entrepreneurial as Paula's or before
someone like Bryan it tho those I would
be I would be looking more towards the
movie industry I think than television
that and that's just a gut feeling of
mine okay oh sorry hi my name is
Catherine urbanek I'm a junior actress
and I was wondering if you guys could
talk about some of the biggest obstacles
that you faced whether it be on the
craft side of things or the business
side of things and what you learned from
those obstacles and how you overcame
them
um you see I i have so many chapters in
my narrative because we all have
narratives our careers are narrow and
our lives you set it as a writer writer
producer creator which is everybody has
a story stephen has a wonderful way of
phrasing things I'm fascinated to you
know hear that that's why your dialogue
and your stories and characters are so
fascinating so I have a very I've many
chapters i have my acting days i have my
agent days of my movie days my producing
days of so many different things but
obstacles that I faced when I got out of
carne I was really naive I really didn't
know anything about the business and I
had a view of the world that was not
quite what it was I perhaps if going
back to did you make a mistake perhaps
as opposed to going to New York or
Hollywood I should have gone into
regional theater and really just
practiced Mike taken everything I
learned and let it solidify because you
need that time to let everything kind of
congeal and and kind of get fixed in
your unconscious so in a way so maybe
going and practicing your craft there
are obstacles to practice practice in
your craft you have to get a job to do
the thing that is your craft and you're
not it's it's a chicken and egg syndrome
of how do you get in it how do you get a
job with that an agent how do you get an
agent without a job and it's really
figuring it out and maneuvering the
system to fit you know two careers that
I have ever worked with or handled we're
the same none there is no definitive
path that's why it's very hard to teach
it you can teach skills but you can't
teach
the specifics of somebody's career your
career will have a very different
dynamic than your career and your career
will take all kinds of fascinating turns
that you'll be surprised about the
obstacles that you put in front of
yourself are the worst kind look to
yourselves first and don't get in your
own way whether as an actor a writer
writers get in their own way directors
get in their own way and actors do so
first remove your own personal
professional obstacles from yourself
that is my first and foremost major
piece of advice about obstacles how do
you overcome your own get in your own
way be willing to confront how you do it
and change it and just not do it
whatever it is we all have those things
we do that you know you know walking in
a room and clutching in an interview and
showing your worst side instead of your
best and sitting down saying why do I do
that to myself that was something I had
to cope with so that's really going up
in and reading and I was a terrific
actress and I edition and I'd clutch why
and then finally when I overcame that I
did something else so the second thing
is to look at the obstacles that people
put in front of you and be strategic in
an inanimate achill way look at how you
can move them out of the way but if they
are cement roadblocks don't keep going
at that roadblock as you're not going to
move through it go around it the
shortest distance between two points is
not always a straight line I know what
that's what you're taught but it's not
in this business not always a straight
line
sometimes that circuitous route out and
around brings you past the obstacle so
think be strategic don't get in your own
way don't let other people get in your
way and if you hit a wall know that
you've got a wall and either climb over
it go around it but don't just keep
hitting your head against the wall you
know most people won't tell you where
when when you make a mistake because
most people don't care enough and
sometimes you're not self observant
enough to to analyze objectively your
own behavior and and it doesn't hurt to
have somebody in your life whether it's
a trusted friend or a therapist if you
can afford that too I'm serious too to
monitor your behavior in a way that
helps you to moderate adjust your
behavior so that so that you don't
provide those self-imposed obstacles
that too often you may not even be aware
anecdotally by way of example I years
ago I had an actor who who came in to
audition for a role and he came in and
he said I can't play this role I said
why not he said I I don't like what the
role represents I have real deep
philosophical issues would you know with
the point of view of the story and well
what you come in for you know you just
wasted 10 minutes of my time telling me
why you shouldn't be here how about just
thanks for the opportunity not available
move on you know that's a behavioral
roadblock that self-imposed I never told
that guy that I didn't care enough I
doubt if he had anybody else in his life
who would who would have told him that
and clearly he wasn't seeing it himself
where he never would have done it so I
had that reminds me give you a quick
story there's a very very well-known
actor I won't say the name because
you'll all know who he is and when I was
at creative artists agency this didn't
happen to me it happened to one of my
colleagues called him up and said guess
what mr. major director just offered you
the major the lead in this film and the
pause and the actor said but I didn't
read for it and he said no I know isn't
that great she just got offered the part
he said no no no no no but I I didn't
read for it said oh but that's the
that's the great thing you already have
the part now we just negotiate the deal
no no I want to read no no no you don't
need to know I won't do the part unless
I read for the director I have to read
for the director big argument ensued no
but you have it don't do no I want the
part but I want to read for it and get
it that way so okay called the director
up and said my client wants to read for
you the director says but he already has
the part I'm sorry he wants to read okay
he wants you to make sure he's right for
the part you just cast him okay he goes
in he reads the director calls the agent
right after and says you know I'm glad
he can't because he's not right for the
part he didn't get the rule just
roosters okay there you go hello my name
is Sophia and i'm a senior music theatre
major and earlier miss Wagner you talked
about luck and you know catching it in
front of you how would you both define
luck and creating our own luck once we
get out there you said it earlier say it
again what did I say I don't know you'd
all remember what you said I hope you do
you say it you said you said it very
well well
luck is the residue of design you know
you work you work your butt off so that
you actually are able to identify what
luck is and when you've worked your butt
off and you can identify it as that
crack in the door you know you go
through it because you have the
confidence of your training everybody
gets lucky just like everybody gets bad
breaks not much you can do about a bad
break except haul yourself up and keep
on trucking but also everybody gets some
luck coming their way and it's only
really luck in retrospect if you were
ready to exploit it my guess is that all
of us have had lucky opportunities that
we just blew you know because either
either we didn't realize what it was at
the time and we only realize in
retrospect or we saw the opportunity but
we weren't ready it's like your
assistant coming in that your would
would be assistant you know what a lucky
break to get to see Paula Wagner and
then to not be prepared to answer you
know basic 101 questions about your
knowledge of the industry you know
that's not taking advantage of your
lucky break again an example that might
be considered luck I started as an agent
at a small agency and I was so fearless
I didn't know any better this is where
ignorance is sometimes really it is
bliss it can be because I would just
call heads of Studios what did I know I
didn't know the pecking order I really
didn't understand business I was just
had a lot of energy and passion for my
clients they were the best actress in
the world and I was going to get them
all jobs and make big deals for them and
I just call anybody that I thought would
listen to me and got myself into every
studio met all the studio heads got on
to the lots of and I you know I'm
blithely going along and calling up
Sherry Lansing hi Paula Wagner who know
I'm an agent too soon so and I'd like to
come in and meet you and talk to you
about my clients they were so taken
aback that I always got in the door and
one day I decided I was going to not
where i was going to start signing
writers and i started pursuing like
well-known writers and I was pursuing a
very well-known writer at the time and
this writer was kind of like you're this
nobody knows who you are at a little
agency I have this big deal agency
called creative artist and a big deal
agent named Fred Specter pursuing me at
creative artists agency and I said I
don't care look what I can offer this is
what I have going for me ba ba ba and CA
a big big agency you don't get the
personal attention you don't get this
and I worked and he almost signed with
me but he didn't because he wanted the
big the big agency so a couple days
later I get a call from a man named Fred
Specter at CAA who says I heard about
you because I just signed this big-time
writer but he said the only reason he
signed was because of the big agency
behind them because he almost signed
with you and we're looking for a female
agent and those were in the days they
called them female you were female
something or mail something and we don't
you know we want to bring in a female
agent would you come in and meet us and
I'm like who creative artists agency I
don't you know
and I'm sure why not and I started
researching it I started looking up this
guy who was running a called michael
ovitz and who was he and Fred Specter
who was he and there was a guy there
named Rick Necedah who was a very well
known as my husband now I very
well-known age in some place I started
analyzing all this I said sure I'll come
in and meet with you the rest was
history I became the first female agent
hired at CAA now I guess you could say
that was a lucky break because I've had
people say to me God how lucky but it
kind of was something that grew out of
something that I was doing that put me
in the right place to get that luck my
way here's a lucky here is an anecdote
about making making your own lucky break
because there's also some risk you know
which is sort of the other the other
side of the luck coin I think in 1964 I
was a sophomore and a Hollywood producer
but in Sam Goldwyn jr. was on a tour of
campuses around the country promoting a
small film that he'd made called the
young lovers and I think it was with
Peter Fonda and I don't remember who the
young actress was and it was an
opportunity just like you know we're
sort of here today it was an opportunity
to see the movie and then we would we
would get an opportunity to have a
question and answer session with Sam
Goldwyn jr. and it was in the little
studio theatre which sad about 80 people
something like that so I was sitting in
the first row and after the movie QA and
I raised my hand and he called on me and
I and I said mr. Goldwyn why is it that
Hollywood seems to always be making you
know at adaptations of novels or plays
or whatever
and that there aren't as many original
stories and screenplays he said well he
said we love original material we just
don't get enough of it so we do you know
we take take it where we can find it so
I took a manila envelope that I brought
with me and I held it up to him and I
said here and he recoiled as if you know
he said oh oh we can't take it because
you know where it creates legal problems
and getting accused of theft and
whatever and okay there was nothing in
the envelope I I don't know what
possessed me to do that
if he had taken the envelope I would
have been the biggest schmuck attack but
as it is he didn't and then that summer
I went out to Los Angeles with my
girlfriend and I slept on my sister's
couch she was a young actress in
Hollywood and the first day I was there
I I called Sam Goldwyn jr. and I said I
don't know if you remember me but I was
at schmuck at Carnegie Tech you know who
tried to hand you oh yeah sure I don't
know whether he really remember not I
said I'm here for the summer and I'm
looking for a summer job could I come
and see it he said ok sure and I went
over right then and there and I talked
my way into a summer job with Sam
Goldwyn jr. it was my first job in the
business and he actually asked me to
stay and I wound up leaving school for a
little while and i stayed eight months
before i came back to finish so that was
an odd that was a situation where i took
a real risk but i created an opportunity
to get in the door because I'd done
something a little brash ok hi my name
is Gabriel King i'm a senior actor we've
been talking about a lot about breaking
into the industry and getting your foot
in the door what i was curious about mr.
bacio you spoke in the last talk about
mark-paul Gosselaar and how you kind of
had him in mind the whole time for
raising the bar and i was curious what
you've seen from actors to kind of make
them the mainstays or give them extended
careers or make them more than just the
talent what are you seeing from people
that might make them your muse or
something like that that goes beyond
just just the everyday actor well that's
a very you know there's an objective
part of it which is all the observable
things of somebody with real talent and
and somebody who
is collaborative and and and works well
in in the ensemble community of the
television series and then there's
there's just an intangible thing it's
like I mean it's almost impossible why
do you fall in love with somebody I
don't know you know I just I'm in love
you know there's just some connection I
mean I don't know why Michael Tucker and
I were bonded so instantly as freshmen
here and and remained absolutely
lifelong friends and I've worked
together many times I mean I don't know
it just that's it happens yes hi my name
is John Mark I'm a freshman designer my
question is Carnegie Mellon they have a
limited number of options for programs
you can take within this realm of drama
if you were interested in something say
producing what steps would you recommend
taking within school and when you get
out into the real world to make to as a
designer to be able to step into that
kind of a different realm well you can
actually and a lot of people do you find
out that producers film producers have
done and been everything yes designers
directors actors produce writers produce
people who come from business produce
venture capitalists produce it really
unfortunately producing is the one Jill
humping I'm on the board to try to
change this that anybody can call
themselves a producer it's a job that's
defined so many different ways by so
many different avenues that you might go
down and it's a it's probably one of the
most demanding jobs in the film business
it used to be Samuel Goldwyn senior that
the producers ran the show
from top to bottom and the director came
on to direct the actual shooting you
know moving around blocking setting up
the camera angles and then the producer
took the film back cut it edited it's
really now what television I think it's
much more like television so what can
you do well first of all do you want to
produce films is that something that's
that you have an interest in I can't
really address television because it's a
it's a different function but for films
yeah you should watch every film you can
see you should know film how it's made
how do you translate a design from stage
to film I was talking about it earlier
today it's different you know how do you
translate that start with your own in
your own backyard as it were no actors
no directors no writers no material have
a good eye for material have a good
technical sensibility have a little bit
of the control freak you want to put
everything together and control it and
handle it of course you can do that that
could be your path but it will take it
will take opening yourself up to
learning as much as you can about every
aspect of the film business and then
going and you get an assisting job with
someone you go work on a film you know
you have there's a young designer who
came out of Carnegie Mellon named Scott
Chambliss who started out with JJ Abrams
and he's now designing big films he
designed mission 3 4 s you design star
trek is a Carnegie Mellon design major
from maybe 10 15 years ago so yes
there's a there's also you're in a great
theater institution here do it now yes
you know pester all of these all of
these professors you know audit their
classes you know broaden your horizons
beyond just design you know sit in on
some of the writing classes if they
won't let you you know
pester them about it find out what plays
they're reading what books they read you
know see if you can audit an acting
class you know I mean use this
incredible environment to your advantage
I might say to you as a designer myself
that it's traveled a very odd path to
end up here is that I think a designer
and often technical support for any
production gets unlimited access and
very unique access to seeing everybody
work it's very rare that you ever get to
see a director work actors get to see a
director work on a certain play a
designer / I've done 150 plays I've seen
150 directors work very few people have
seen that very few people have worked
with management on advertising very few
people have seen what the money is but a
designer is ideally placed as is a
technical director as is a production
manager and I think if your ideas veer
away from one silo which I'd encourage
everybody in the room to think about
this is the ideal place to do it and a
designer is ideally placed for us here's
the next question hey yeah hello my name
is Abdiel Yvonne cose I'm a sophomore
musical theatre major and first I want
to thank you both for coming and sharing
time with us my question stems from
seeing some great alumni over the last
year and a half speak to us and listen
to us and wanting to listen more so what
are some practical ways that you've
maintained and developed some
professional relationships and what
would you earn us to do we'll meet
people like you you're doing it you know
I mean I think in every session that
we've had over the last two days Paul
and I have have opened our doors in a
sense neither one of us is saying old
give you a job you know but but we are
saying we will make ourselves accessible
if and as you get out there
you know I just said over here you don't
call me i'll tell you whether you know
I'll find out for you oh that that's
that's a legitimate agent or manager
whatever it is if I'm casting a show you
know I'll set something up so you can
come in and read for us maintain that
you know take advantage of that in the
course of four years I'm sure there are
a lot of interesting professional people
who come through the doors here to say
hello and spend a day or two as we are
take advantage of those you know you
have a network of friends here who are
going to fan out all over the country
New York Chicago Los Angeles maintain
it's so much easier to maintain
relationships today than it was you know
40 years ago 44 years ago whenever was
that I graduated you know the internet
bomb on you know email you you can stay
connected to this community as it fans
out all over America so easily you don't
have to write a letter you don't have to
lick a stamp you don't have to pay six
dollars for long distance phone call and
all those things with which 40 some odd
years ago made it daunting in terms of
maintaining relationships I'll just
different couple of minutes make a list
of every alumni we're going to get
everybody's gonna you're going to call
all the alumni well they all said yeah
tell them Steven Bochco said call no but
make a list of all the key alumni din
the areas that you're going to go into
make a list make it methodical really
sit down in those moments when I was
kind of my own agent my own entrepreneur
Mona
sit down every day and devote myself to
what am I going to do today to further
my career and how am I going to do it
okay here's a list of every alumni
that's in California or everybody that's
in New York and it's interesting and you
you you can network back with your
former professors and teachers and talk
to people did you know the person who
created the starbucks logo is a carnegie
mellon graduate i didn't know that
either i read about it so there are some
really interesting people there are some
writers in hollywood on television shows
writer/producers as a guy as a show
runner who graduated from Carnegie
Mellon in biology or something having
note was not so there are some very
interesting connections to be made make
those connections number to be a decent
human being when somebody meets you and
goes out of their way email and thanks a
lot send them a note sent him an email
people love that think of the other
person just basic sensitivity to the
other person and that maintains your
connections thank you for seeing me hope
all is well or you know you had a great
success with that congratulations just
little things that maintain
relationships at the basis of Hollywood
is relationships because it's basically
a very small town fantastic well I think
we might have to draw to a close it's
just after four o'clock I'd like to
thank our guests very much just think at
the moment you're sitting here looking
at them thinking they are very famous
and celebrated people I know that
nothing will give them greater pleasure
then doing the reverse and watching you
on the screen you on stage watching last
night in Grapes of Wrath doing the
things that they do looking out at you
and seeing the talent that's going to
emerge you will be up on those screens
in a couple of years you will be on the
Woodman stage you will be on Broadway
and I'm sure it will give poor and Steve
an enormous pleasure to see you there